Brasil un país dividido la presidencia
del gigante latinoamericano se debatirá
en una segunda vuelta de alto voltaje el
izquierdista Luis Ignacio lulada Silva
se alzó con la victoria la primera
vuelta electoral sin lograr la mayoría
necesaria
siempre creí que íbamos a ganar estas
elecciones y lo que puedo decir es que
vamos a ganar estas elecciones
[Aplausos]
esto es solo una prórroga
importante
lo importante en la segunda vuelta son
las propuestas para la sociedad
a diferencia del tono festivo de sus
seguidores en las calles un eco de
desilusión se palpó en el discurso del
expresidente puesto que los sondeos
brasileños le daban una sólida ventaja
muchos ahora cuestionan su fiabilidad se
trata de la cuarta segunda vuelta a la
que se enfrenta el líder del partido de
los trabajadores un cara a cara con el
actual presidente de extrema derecha
Jair bolsonaro el líder del partido
liberal sacó músculo con un resultado
mayor al esperado
la confianza total la confianza porque
se desenmascararon de una vez las
encuestas datafolia nos situaba en 51
frente al 30 y pico la diferencia fue de
cuatro puntos entonces todo eso ayuda a
que el voto se vaya para el otro lado
el tercer lugar se lo llevó simonetebett
candidata la mano derecha con casi 45
millones de votos que ahora deben
canalizar los dos candidatos rivales y
quizás sus votos
sean a personal Brasil está bocado a un
mes más de contienda en medio de una
polarización extrema y el run run de
fraude electoral impulsado por el
ultraderexista bolsonaro la premisa de
que ambos candidatos darán la pelea en
las calles los debates previos al 30 de
octubre